uh ukan cedan and
cens thanks intro and thanks for the
workshop and program organizers for
putting together Straight
program um yeah so I'll be talking about
the this thing right here and the goal
is very humble all we want to do is just
cluster stream end points in space
that's little o vogin yeah so um
actually I don't think that in spite of
all the talks so far we've actually
introduced clustering so let me just
give a brief introduction even though a
lot of you guys are probably familiar
okay so we have an input data set X
that's what appears on the left of your
screen and the goal is to partition X so
that some notion of similar points are
in the same cluster and different points
are in different clusters okay there are
a lot of ways to do this but uh the
notion that we'll consider is called K
clustering and that's just where there's
a fixed number K uh of clusters that we
want to partition the data set into okay
so for k equal three the natural
partitioning would be into the two
clusters right your
screen
okay all right so um there are many ways
to measure the quality of each
clustering the way we're going to do it
is that we're going to assign Center to
each
clustering uh to each cluster in the
clustering and then we'll have a cost
function that's induced by the
center uh for all the points in the
partition Pi that's assigned to uh
CI okay so we're going to assume in this
talk that the points are living in some
Metric space with a distance function
and for each cluster of points so Pi is
points the cost induced by pi due to the
center CI is going to be some function
of uh the distances of the points in the
cluster to the center okay and then more
generally the overall clustering cost is
going to be a function of the um cost
induced by each
partition so this is the overall
clustering cost we have a set of centers
C there K centers here x is our data set
so this is a function of the overall
sets of
distances okay pretty standard stuff so
just as a quick illustration let's
suppose that we have a set of
points and there's only one Center then
the common K Center metric is just we
take the largest distance between the
center and some point K median is the
sum of the
the distances K means is the sum of the
square distances and KZ clustering is
sum of the zth powers right and of
course you can see that for Z equals 1
it's K median Z equals 2 it's K me so on
so
forth and again just simplify things
what we're going to be doing in our talk
is just considering ukian K clustering
so we'll have end points that are in um
D dimensional space but furthermore
they're actually between one and Delta
so they're integers between one and
Delta and you can think of Delta as some
kind of aspect ratio or accuracy or
granularity so that uh you know if your
input isn't all integers you can round
down or like bit Precision you can round
down uh or scale down so that
everything's a multiple of uh some
integer okay and since we're in the ukan
distance we have the standard L2
distance for uh distance function right
so in summary this is the problem that
we're going to be
at okay so that's clustering and um I
promise you that I would be looking at
something in a streaming model so here's
streaming model we have an underlying
data set X that arrives sequentially
like so and the goal is to evaluate or
approximate some given function using
space that's sublinear in the size n of
the data
set and for us um again we're going to
be a bit more demanding and just do this
in login space okay so now hopefully uh
this whole sentence should be crystal
clear
okay so our main results are for
insertion only stream which is exactly
the example that you saw in the previous
slide where this the points arrive in
the data set and then they never go
away there's one past algorithm that uh
works for clustering at all times in the
Stream and it uses um space that is
sublinear in uh log n and furthermore
these higher order terms match the best
known construction well I guess almost
up the best known
Construction in fact for those who are
familiar with corsets um our algorithm
actually outputs a OnePlus Epsilon coret
construction for all times in the Stream
for those of us who are not familiar
with corsets you will be in a few slides
okay okay so there's a related model
which is insertion deletion and in that
setting your points can arrive and then
at some later point they could disappear
and this model is often more difficult
and indeed we show that uh if we want a
constant Factor approximation there is a
separation so even if you just want a
two
approximation um if you want to do this
for all times in the Stream then you
need to use log squared n Bits of square
uh
space uh oh I should say that in the
previous model we're saying that um this
is words of space so if we're looking at
bit complexity there's still uh log n or
log Delta in the dependency and this is
often necessary to store just the
points okay so for um Dynamic streams if
we want a constant Factor approximation
at all times
squ and furthermore if we want to do
this from a weighted subset of the
input we also need lock
squ okay so that seems a bit
pessimistic so um we show that for two
stream uh two passes over the insertion
deletion stream we can actually get an
algorithm that does use little o login
space right so this also shows a
separation between one and two passes uh
this may not be surprising because
there's been a lot of beautiful work
that shows that you can do a lot more
interesting things and you're low more
passes over the
stream and finally i' like to mention
that one of the structural results that
we gave is a sum of the so-called online
sensitivities which which I'll also go
over in a
bit but we see that this Su of the
online sensitivities of a set of
endpoints is at most klog
squared and this is useful in other
applications for example if you're
familiar with the sliding window model
it's been shown recently that you can
view the sliding window model as like a
reverse online sensitivity so this
actually gives an easy algorithm for
OnePlus Epsilon approximation for
clustering in the sliding window
model it doesn't give the optimal one
but even uh the first one plus Epsilon
result was just shown at soda last year
so this gives a much simpler
approach okay so uh those are our
results and uh now as promised I'll talk
about what a COR set is so if you have a
set X that is our data set a core set is
a subset X Prime of Representative
points and the goal of course is that
the cost of a set of Cent C on X Prime
should be roughly the cost of C on the
original data set
X and this should actually hold for all
sets of centers C that have K points so
this is what's known as a strong
coret so pictor this is what it looks
like had a set of
points and uh we choose a weighted
subset of these points right so maybe we
choose one point here two points here so
on and so forth so here are the red
points would be the
coret and this is one notion of what it
means for the cost of um the original
data set to be preserved so I should
mention that uh for corsets uh if we
want anything interesting if we want to
subset sample like a smaller set of
points then they need to be weighted
right so so this is actually a weighted
[Applause]
cost okay so what's known about corsets
is that actually there exist coret
constructions that only require K Over
Epsilon squ times let's say okay let's
say uh for the purpose of our talk K squ
Over Epsilon squar
points um weighted points of the input
right so this is result by Co andad
Casper over there uh and some others in
fact this has been improved uh so uh
there's a result that gets I think um K
to the 3es over Epsilon
squ but the key point is that this is
independent of the input size
n okay so this result is telling us that
there exists some subset of the input
that is completely independent of the
original input size and it somehow
preserves all the important properties
of input size that we care
about and so hopefully this makes more
sense as motivation for why I want to
study this in the streaming
model I see some f brows any questions
yeah so here any course setep you can
just use it in the streaming like
immediately and it will give you
some
create yes that is exactly correct so I
will okay it's not the next slide but in
a few slides you can use it um but
because uh you have this merch tree that
you're talking about you'll lose log
factors
L you remind me what Z stands for here
oh Z is the power of uh like clustering
the how much we scale each cost by the
exponent so I guess if it makes things
easier you should think of Z as either
one for K median or Z equals two for K
means thank
you okay any other sorry any other
questions okay so if not then uh we'll
talk about exactly what Seer is asking
which is what you can do with these
coret constructions in a stream and
there's a popular framework that's known
as merge and reduce and and what it does
is the following so Suppose there exists
a 1 plus Epsilon corset construction for
K means there is because well I just
showed it to you in the previous slide
and it uses some function of uh weighted
input points and like I said before you
can think of this as K squ Over Epson
squ even though that's not the most
optimal so what we're going to do is
we're going to partition the stream into
blocks that
contain um roughly K squ Over Epson squ
points
okay and now the point is that we're
going to look at each block and make a
core set on that block and because that
block is exactly the number of points in
the coret well the coret is the entire
set of
points and now once we have a core set
for each
block then what we can do is we can take
two consecutive blocks take the core
sets for those blocks put them together
that's another set of weighted points
and then Resale by running another coret
algorithm on this Union
[Applause]
of so putting these two corses together
is the merge part of the merge and
reduce and then running the corset
algorithm afterwards on the union is
redu
part and Seer said the words exactly
like there's this binary tree and here
it is so you have the stream at the
bottom you break it up into blocks and
then you run this binary tree and the
course at the top is going to be the
coret for the entire
stream because we have actually 1 plus
Epsilon over log in right this is where
the uh login Over N comes from so we
have a finer accuracy for each cor set
then as we scale up to login levels
we're going to lose this Factor like
roughly login times but this is still
going to be roughly one plus
Epsilon so that's a very simple way of
getting a streaming algorithm for
clustering if you have a coret
construction and of course this applies
to other uh things besides clustering if
you also have coret constructions like
there are a lot of things in linear
algebra uh regression that's often
useful when we have for construction yes
n at the start of the problem let's say
you know an upper bound on
N okay so yeah for K means clustering if
you take all these calculations this is
roughly like k^ squ over Epsilon
squ uh so we do lose some of these log
factors and you can imagine situations
where K is small and Epsilon is you know
constant the N Factor could really blow
up the overall space
usage okay
um so yeah like I said you know this is
where the K squ Epsilon squ comes from
so now
uh this really motivates our question
like can we beat these standard
techniques do there exist streaming
algorithms that use little o login fors
of
[Applause]
space so our result I guess again is yes
there's been a long line of works that
uh all have these login dependencies so
what we actually do is we first show
this online sensitivity sampling
technique here so that still has a login
dependency it beats a lot of the
previous known balance it's it's really
simple but then we also use it to we
feed it into our uh ultimate
algorithm okay so that is the background
and next I'll talk about insertion only
streams maybe I'll stop really briefly
again Ask for
questions oh oh great great okay so the
question was what is the output again
and uh cam is perfectly right if we want
to Output like the actual clustering of
the points there's no way you can do
that in sublinear uh space so what we
want to Output is the centers for the
clustering okay so it's not like some
online assignment to these centers it is
not an online assignment right at the
end of the stream I'll give you K point
or I guess at every point in time I'll
give you K points and these K points
will be pretty close to the optimal set
of centers that you can do okay
thanks okay all right so if there are no
more questions then we'll talk about
coret constructions and sampling and uh
this is something that pilter alluded to
yesterday so he said that if you've seen
important
sampling this is all pretty standard and
well here is important
sampling okay so consider a a fixed set
X so that's our uh data set and a set of
a c that's also fixed of K
centers so it's going to induce some
fixed cost which I'll denote here and we
would like to approximate this cost
right so again here we have a set of
points in yellow and the triangles are
the centers so K goes three
here okay so a simple way to obtain X
Prime is just to uniformally sample
points of X into X
Prime so we get a subset of points
afterwards um that will have the right
expectation depending on the number of
samples you take that could have really
high
variance and indeed if there's a point
out here this is going to contribute
most of the cost to this clustering
right because uh each of these points is
not going to contribute that much cost
so unless we sample this point we're not
going to get a good approximation of
this fixed
cost but of course we're smarter than
that we know that uniform sampling is
almost never the way to go so instead we
do important
sampling and so we sample each point
with probity proportional to its cost
okay so um this set of points will
induce some fixed costs and this
particular point will induce a fixed
cost so we're going to sample this point
with probity proportional to the ratio
of how much this point induces versus
the overall
cost and you can imagine that if points
are more important because they
contribute more to the cost then we're
obviously sampling these points with
higher
probability so this ratio Right Here is
known as the sensitivity uh of the point
and um important sampling needs uh X
Prime to have size only roughly one over
Epsilon squared to achieve a 1 plus
Epsilon
approximation and this is because we
have a fixed set of centers
C now um the problem is that we could
have a different choice of case centers
so if we actually move this center from
this original partition over here to
this point right here suddenly this
point no longer looks
important and remember for clustering we
actually want to do this for all
possible sets of centers because we want
to recover the optimal set of
centers okay so instead of looking at
this ratio um for one set set of centers
we're going to look at uh this ratio for
all possible sets of centers so this Max
C here should be over all possible
choices of C where the cality C is at
most
K and this is known as the uh sorry this
is known as the sensitivity of point
x okay so if we want to handle all
possible sets of case centers there are
two things we need to do first we need
to generalize the sampling probability
to this notion of sensitivity sampling
and then afterwards we still need to so
so then we have correctness for one set
of centers we still need to Union bound
over a net of all possible sets of K
centers okay and it turns out that the
net size is roughly in Delta over
Epsilon
[Applause]
KD um so even if we uh take a union
bound over this we'll C login
dependencies here okay so uh I I don't
know how to do important sampling or
sensitivity sampling without a login
dependency um
yeah okay so again you know this is the
sensitivity of the point x and if we
take the sum of these values over all
the points in the data set that gives us
a notion of how many points we expect to
sample overall because we're sampling
each point with probity proportional to
its sensitivity
so the expectation the expected number
of total points is roughly the total
sensitivity so this quantity um gives us
intuition on how many points will be
sampled into the set X
Prime um so that's good and everything
but for us it there's a problem with
this framework right uh this requires us
to actually know the entire data set X
in advance to calculate the sensitivity
of a
point but we get these points in a
stream so we can't do this
fortunately there's a related notion um
called online sensitivity um I think one
of the first contexts it was considered
was in uh regression by cam
authors um so instead of looking at the
contribution of a point to the overall
data set in terms of cost we look at the
ratio of the point to the overall data
set that has arrived so
far so how far a point is with respect
to the prefix a points have arrived so
you can tell immediately that the online
sensitivity is bigger than the overall
sensitivity but how much bigger can it
be okay so again the online sensitivity
is the same ratio but now uh this point
here the denominator is uh XT it's the
cost of the set of centers with respect
to the first T
[Applause]
points okay so the algorithm is simple
we're just going to sample each point
with property proportional to its online
sensitivity and uh there's still two
issues though like how first of all how
do we compute the online sensitivity and
then second what is the sum of the
online
sensitivities okay so um if we have a
core
set if we have a OnePlus Epson coret
which is ultimately our goal but let's
suppose for some reason that we have one
then I claim we can actually use the
coret to obtain approximation to the
sensitivity
and this is because the coret is already
promising us that for any choice of K
centers it's going to preserve the cost
up to one plus Epsilon
approximation so this coret is already
going to give us what's in the
denominator of uh this quantity right
here so um by the way I didn't mention
this clustering is quite hard there are
results that say that it's empty hard to
even approximate so we're not going to
care about runtime in this talk okay um
so now if we have this core set what we
can do is we can brute force over all
choices of our K centers until we find a
quantity that uh is
maximal and that will give us uh our
online
sensitivity so now we can kind of do
this in lock step like I I claim that if
I am doing online sensitivity sampling
I'll have a core set of the first like T
minus one points I have a core set so
now I can use this core set to compute
the next probability sample it and then
I'll have a COR set of the you know the
first T points and so on so
forth right okay so this is pretty
standard uh uh yeah the whole claim is
that we can just do this uh
online and given our new balance on
total total sensitivity uh I claim that
the overall coret size is uh k squ d
over Epson squ and unfortunately we're
losing poly factors here so it's a
simple algorithm it doesn't give us our
goal but uh it gives us new
understanding on the structure of these
[Applause]
problems all right um so how big can
these total sensitivities
be um well I guess the spoiler alert is
that uh uh the total sensitivities that
most like you know KD is but uh let's
let's look an
example so um if we have a set of seven
points and uh six centers
then if we assign if we choose our
centers like so then this point has
sensitivity one because uh this thing is
the entire cost right these points each
consider uh contribute since uh cost
zero this thing contributes cost non
zero so it has sensitivity one now let's
shift the centers around and you can see
that this point also has sensitivity
one so so
forth right so it's easy to see that the
total sensity can be at least K because
here we have K plus one points in K
centers each point has sens one okay
order
K all right uh but how large can it be
and turns out we can do some math but
the the point is that um if we have a
set of points and a set of centers so
these are clearly not the optimal
centers but they still could um be the
value at which the online sensitivity is
realized in the sense that maybe even
though these are suboptimal centers
maybe these are the choices for which
this maximum is
[Applause]
obtained now there's a simple charging
argument so so here is the ratio that
this is let's say we consider the the
the ratio for this point here is the
distance between this point and the
center so that's the quantity in the
numerator and let's suppose that these
are the optimal Cent St so there's a
simple charging argument we can do a
triangle inequality and we can partition
the sum of the sensitivities by each
cluster so I can say that well um I can
consider this ratio for just the points
X in this uh Center sorry in this
cluster that's defined by the optimal
St and the sum of the ratios for each
partition will be at most one and then
there are K clusters so this goes to
show that the uh overall sums can be at
most order
[Applause]
K so what's happening here is what we're
what we're really doing is we're saying
that there's a partitioning a natural
partitioning that's defined by the
optimal choice of the centers and once
we have this partitioning then we
consider the the ratios in each of these
partitionings um and show that each
cluster has uh the sums at most one and
since there are K clusters then the the
sum of the sensitivities is most order
K so this is an offline setting in
online setting uh things can be worse
because the points are arriving over
time but you can do some simple tricks
like you can consider you can divide the
stream into to times where the overall
clustering cost
doubles this will give you one log n and
then you can also think of um how much
uh contribution a point can contribute
within um a period of time when the uh
the optimal cluster and cost doubles and
that gives you
[Applause]
another okay so what's the point of all
this uh well we can perform online City
sampling and this will give us a new
stream X Prime right X Prime you could
think of as just the points that we
sampled so this stream will have points
like uh K2 d^2 Epsilon squ whatever like
some factors in k d EPS one over Epsilon
and polylog n Delta
right and now we can do the same trick
that we did before we can run merge and
reduce and the point was that merge and
reduce incurred these log factors
because we have the binary tree incurred
these log factors in the length of the
stream but now we have this new
artificial stream that doesn't have an N
Factor there there are no polinomial n
factors in the length of the stream it's
just poly log n so the polylog N factors
will be poly log log n factors here
okay so this algorithm is super simple
and it uh does exactly what we wanted so
the new stream has small length run
mergin reduce and then overall the the
total space is uh going to
be okay pretty simple algorithm nice
warmup questions
yeah uh so why Canal do this like a
why not do the online sensitivity
sampling
again um because uh so you can do this
again to get factors of uh just play
like n but uh because you need to Union
bound over the net we we didn't do this
because you'll lose like K
bors so so if your goal is just achieve
little login which I guess was our
original goal then then what you said
works yeah
thank you so we just want to be slightly
more ambitious and get like the optimal
factors here as
well uh
R not sure if this is the exact same
question or not but basically uh can you
just do this more and more layers can
you get like poly log staren by taking
your now merge reduced stream and then
introducing that
again um you can't get okay so uh can't
get poly log factories because uh well
you'll always have the uh k squ d log uh
Epson Square oh you're asking about play
log star factors in in
N
um yeah a question I don't see
not
adds
mer well I think he's asking about uh
online sensity sampling not merge and
reduce what does that oh oh sorry sorry
for online sensity sampling when you
sample points that they'll be the the
sensitivities will be higher so like
after you after a while all the all the
points will have like sensitivity really
high sensitivity so we sample all them
Prett
much oh okay gotcha cool
thanks
so so this analysis uh clearly depends
upon your uh data being ukian um but can
you translate any part of this algorithm
or the algorithm framework to uh like
non- ukian data like maybe your data is
like sequences of symbols with a Lenin
distance or something or does it like
fundamentally violate some tricks you're
using yeah it's a good question
um well I guess the first thing that
comes to mind is that our proof for uh
the sum of online entities really relied
on the fact that our data is ukan
because we do these triangle
inequalities uh so you'll still have
triangle inequalities but uh I guess the
question is how much distortion
um I don't see the answer to your
question right now but maybe okay thank
you so given
um a set of end points
um can you give any advice as to how to
choose the proper value of
K no I think that's a complete
orthogonal question uh choosing the
right value of K especially in a stream
I don't see how to do I mean I guess you
know there are these popular elbow
methods for seeing uh you look at these
various values of K and see which one
gives you like the most difference you
have to iterate basically yeah yeah I
don't see a way of doing this for for a
stream I mean if you have an upper bound
you can do all these simultaneously like
if you have an upper bound on what you
think could be K uh you can do all you
can do this simultaneously for all these
values but uh but if you don't have an
upper bound I don't see a way of doing
this especially because the the order of
the stream can be
adversarial um it can be arbitrary so
maybe what you think is the right value
K is suddenly not the right value K
because you get more
information so uh if you do do that like
if you do have an upper value bound the
value of K is your like overhead just K
or can you do something like cheaper
than like just doing like K copies of
this one for each setting of K uh no I
think you're upper bound I mean it still
be K because uh for the the highest
value of K then you still need sample
all these
Point s what I mean is like when you do
it for the highest value of
K do you
have copies in parall yeah exactly do
you have to run like three like K copies
in parallel like four like settings of K
from like one to like you know upper
bound or like your question is like
whether we need to gain an additional
factor of K yeah uh I don't think so I
guess it's question of whether these uh
sensitivity values are monotone as K
goes up I think they should be
um yeah and if they are uh then then you
don't need to do this uh you can just
choose your highest value of K and then
uh those sampling probabilities will
dominate what you would have chosen for
once
so uh does this algorithm use all K
given really well I'm thinking about
that suppose
the the original data
has five clusters and you give it like K
of seven so it will still use all
seven um so I guess can can it tell me
okay five is enough so we didn't use all
of
them so at the end of the stream it'll
give you a core set so it'll give you a
weighted subset of points that uh will
give you a good approximate of any uh
set of centers so then if you want you
can look at this set of points at the
end and say all right now I'm going to
set k equals 5 what is the optimal cost
here then I can set k equal seven what
is the optimal cost here and this data
structure will allow you to make all
these queries and still be accurate cost
various values of K and of centers so
you're saying that in postprocessing we
can reduce that to the
minimal uh really necessary
ENT
um I am saying that uh we can run the
elble method postprocessing that's right
as long as we have an upper bound on on
K like the the value that we
want okay so if there are more no more
questions then we'll go into uh K Median
on Dynamic streams and um I'd like to
just mention that what I said pretty
much doesn't doesn't work for dynamic
streams because if we do online City
sampling if we sample something then it
goes away then we're pretty much in
trouble so we need some new Frameworks
Al together but at the same time there
are some observations we can make that
uh still uh make the the first part of
talk
relevant okay so uh one thing we can do
is we can generalize this notion of
sensitivity so that um each point has a
sensitivity even if it's not in original
data
[Applause]
set and now this could be bad because we
have no idea what the sum of the
sensitivities are but the point is that
if we sample some of these points with
probability proportional to this this
mystical quantity and then the point
goes away then uh if we if as long as we
still sample the original points with
the right probability we'll be
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to use the first pass of the
stream to set up some data structure
that allow us to estimate the
sensitivity of each point in the
Stream and then in the second pass we
won't perform sensitivity sampling but
we'll essentially simulate it in some
way all right so just as a reminder you
know sensitivity sampling is uh this
ratio that we all know and maybe Love by
now um so let's I promise you that if we
have a approximate set of centers that
are near optimal so let's suppose that s
is uh it's a weighted set but if it's a
weighted set of K centers that's near
optimal then I can use this to find the
sensitivities of each point
roughly in other words rather than have
um the cost of a point x um instead of
having this ratio instead of having the
cost of the entire data set x with
respect to a set of Center c um once I
know s then I can break down this
denominator and the point is for each
query I can compute this denominator
explicitly I think I'm confused by
what's stated in the claim because in
the definition of s ofx there's a Max
over C yes in the claim there's just a c
yes so what do you mean there ah okay so
I should say that um this quantity is a
good approximation of this quantity
without the Max and so if we maximize
over all of these quantities then won't
be able to get a good approxim of the
true
s so we still don't care about runtime
so uh what we're going to do is we're
going to find this s and then we're
going to compute this value for all
possible sets of centers and then we'll
take again the the quantity that
maximizes this
ratio okay so there's a little bit of
math I'll skip this part in the interest
time but it's nothing more than just
tryangle inquality and the optimality of
the choice
us so in short if we can use the first
pass to find the a near optimal set of
centers and uh you know the weights
assigned to each of these centers then
in the second pass we can figure out
what is the probability that we should
sample each
point now how do we do this we can't use
this sampling procedure anymore we can't
use uh merge and reduce so it turns out
that another popular method in um these
clustering problems is uh quadry
embedding filter talked about this a bit
yesterday so we have a set of points
we're just going to build a grid over
this so remember again that the aspect
ratio is Delta meaning that uh each of
these points in any direction is
separated by most Delta so let's build a
box around these points with a side
length Delta we'll shift this randomly
to make sure that there aren't any
adversarial uh
dependencies and now all we do is uh we
just look at the number of points inside
this grid okay so uh this is probably
either 18 or
17 okay and now we do this for multiple
Dimensions or multiple layers so we
split it again split it
again so I think Piller talked about
this yesterday in the context of runtime
what we're actually going to do is use
this in the context of
space so one thing you can do is you can
view this grid
and all you care about is the number of
points inside each cell in each Grid at
each
level so you have a frequency Vector of
Dimension one you have a frequency
Vector of Dimension four or two to the
D so on so
forth okay so why is the quatu embedding
useful well let's suppose we have a set
of weighted centers so that means that
we think that six points will be
assigned to the center some points will
be assigned to this this center six
points be assigned to this
Center the quatri will tell us um a good
approximation of the cost of this
clustering so um all the points are
within this box at the top so the cost
induced is zero now we have the split
and um there are six points here in the
cell and uh there's capacity six here so
there's no cost induced by this cell
similar here but now here we're in
trouble right because this cell has
capacity seven and this cell uh has cost
seven so this level will induce a cost
of seven which is the difference of
these things times Delta over
two okay and we can do this so on and so
forth now the point is that this cost is
just a sum of the differences of the
values in each cell so if you think of
this as a frequency vector or two
frequency vectors it's the L1 Norm of
the difference of the frequency
vectors up to some scaling where you
multiply by the
grd okay so the quadry embedding will
give us some
Distortion but the ultimate goal is that
we're going to be able to embed this
quad tree into an L1 uh embedding and
there are algorithms known for
approximating L1 in a
stream
all right so they're better embeddings
than the one I just showed but uh the
point is that uh this one will have uh
slightly worse space or sorry slightly
worse accuracy but better space so if
you don't want some of these terms you
can use a bit more space and be a bit
more
accurate okay so the point is that the
quadry embedding produces a vector
Dimension uh Delta to the D and again
I've already mentioned how this can be
viewed as an L1
of the frequency
vector and there exist streaming
algorithms that are allowing you to
approximate the L1 of the frequency
vector and it uses log space so log here
will be dlog Delta for us uh we don't
care about the log Delta because it goes
into
the okay so the algorithm is pretty
simple for those of uh you who remember
um all you do is just generate a number
of Cy random variables you take the dot
product of the frequency Vector with
these C variables and take the median
and that's going to be a good
approximation of the
L1 so by putting these two these two
things together first I have you know
this um EMD embedding this Quarry
embedding and then um an L1 Norm
approximation algorithm on top of that
we get a One path streaming algorithm
that outputs a z such that uh Z is close
to um the EMD here and really what you
should view the EMD is the optimal cost
of the clustering I kind of change
notations a bit but this is the optimal
cost of the
clustering and remember why did we want
care about the optimal cost of the
clustering it's because this will allow
us to compute the sensitivities of each
[Applause]
point okay so um yeah we generalized
some previous work to show that uh it
suffice to Union bound over a smaller
net but the point is now there's a
certain sketch size that is um using
less than log n wordss of space and
allows to find a good approximation to
the optimal cost along with the centers
that induce this
[Applause]
cost so the summary is as
follows um there's some streaming
algorithm that will give us a good
capacitated set of centers along with
with an approximation of his costs and
that will allow us to estimate the
sensitivities okay so pass one we're
done we can estimate the sensitivities
of all points what do we do for past two
we still can't really do sensitivity
sampling because if we sample each point
they can be
deleted but uh if we do know that if we
do sensitivity sampling things will be
sparse there will be only like roughly
KD points that we
sample so what we should do is not
sample points of the data stream but
sample points from the overall
Universe okay so we say that for each
point in the universe we're going to
include it in like a substream with a
probability that roughly is can be
interpreted as its
sensitivity and this universe will be
pretty sparse in terms of the number of
points that are in this universe that
actually arrive in the
Stream because if they're too much then
and this
violates the the balance that we
computed for the total
sensitivity and so we can just run
sparse recovery on this um second
stream so
again we have an implicit stream we'll
have a small number of
points at the end of the stream and
so
okay so um I'll skip over this
since time but it's just an algorithm
that talks about the guarantees of Spar
recovery but our entire algorithm is as
follows first pass we set the EMD sketch
what does that mean that means we have
spatry embedding have the L1 sketch on
top of that and then we have a procedure
that allows us to recover a near optimal
set of
centers that's the first
pass second pass we sample elements with
property proportional to there into
this artificial stream and then
[Applause]
run so that
is
yes um forgive seems like a dumb
question but this is a
stream of points that is dynamic that it
means uh there's possible deletions yes
there are possible deltion
now so when are these deletions
occurring oh uh these deletions can
occur whenever the stream demands let's
just say that the stream is consistent
so that it won't try to delete a point
that hasn't been added yet but uh yeah
your stream could be I'm going to insert
this point over here then I'm going to
insert this point over here now I'm
going to delete this first point so on
and so forth I'm talking about your your
process you first first do one pass yeah
and then before you do the second pass
are there deletions there are deletions
in the first pass inter Le within the
first pass interleaved at any time in
the first pass time and also in the
second pass uh the second pass we're
going to say is uh I guess it doesn't
even need to be the same order as second
as first
[Applause]
pass yeah it's the same stram it is the
same
stream okay
than so
in uh the insertion deletion stream is
the basic reason that you avoid the
login barrier again because you're sort
of doing this like simulated implicit
stream layer or what part of this allows
you to avoid the login
part um okay so there are a couple
things the first is that this embedding
um is void allowing us to avoid the
login dependency make uh this quad
stream Bing uh you know it's not
accurate but uh only has
login bits of space and same with the L1
sketch and the sparse recovery and then
in the second pass it's like we're doing
sensitivity
sampling uh without okay so the second P
part is sort of the same intuition as
the insertion only part as to why I've
always log in no no it's like an offline
version now because know the
sensitivities whereas the first pass in
one pass it's like an online version and
the sum of the online ones incurs login
factors uh offline we don't have these
uh dependencies so it's yeah the the
correct intuition I guess is that the
second pass can be used to simulate
offline City sampling where you already
have an estimation of your whole data
set cool thank
[Applause]
you
does your lower bound also hold if the
stream is structured in the sense that
like first it's only insertions and then
only
deletions
um does our lower bound hold in the case
where it's only insertion first
insertions and then only deletions yes
in fact that is exactly our
[Applause]
construction
sensitive um order sensitive in what
sense sorry the question was is the
lower bound order
sensitive is the algorithm order
sensitive oh the algorithm is not order
sensitive uh it needs to be able to
handle uh any order any order the same
guarantee yes the same guarantee and I
still keep thinking about figuring out
sort of optimal K so we don't know how
many clusters are there we don't not so
if we give it K is is too large which
means the coret is redundant so you're
saying we can sort of randomly remove
try to remove some points and see if
cost blows up or something well if K is
too large all it means is that we have a
bigger coret than we need right so how
can we figure out the optimal K so
remove the redundancy let's say oh um
well uh one way to do this would be to
uh evaluate the corep on different
values of K uh figure out which optimal
value of K you want and then you can so
run a coret algorithm for that value of
K
afterwards yeah and can we at least
detect this situation when K was not
enough so okay here's
your K size coret but you really need to
bump it
up um when K is not
enough more clusters in the data there
are more clusters
please give us some indication that this
happened no I don't see a way of doing
this yeah I don't see because even our
estimators have some dependency in K so
uh if your value of K is too large I
don't see a way of
estimating it's too too small if it's
too small yes if it's too sorry if your
value of K is too small I don't see a
way of handling this if your value of K
is too large you might be inefficient in
your space but we can do some post pring
afterwards to figure
[Applause]
out okay just just to be clear if you
mean value of K is too small and too
small means the cost is larger than you
wanted or something I guess you'll
notice that because you can see the cost
that you got and a flag can we
distinguish this situation then
really more clusters on the data so ke
was not enough yeah I guess the question
is what uh permits you to notice that
your value of K is too small like is it
a hard threshold or is it like some
other you know is it like uh there
there's some choices of K that suddenly
make your clustering c yeah we're asking
give us K size coret and possibly a flag
saying was it enough or not is it like
are we in the bad situation when we
missed some clusters
yeah um I think the answer to that
really depends on what conditions you
want to raise a flag
with yeah yeah let's uh take
this okay um so I have five minutes left
so uh I just like to remind you about um
K median you know the the two things are
step one we have this AMD sketch step
two we run spice recovery for K means uh
the main issue is that quatri doesn't
work anymore so uh this is actually a
problem that that shows up over and over
again um there are a lot of papers that
use the quatri for K median and then for
K means uh they need to do something
else so what we do here oh first let let
me talk about why the K median sorry why
quatri fail for K means the issue is
that your Distortion really depends on
uh how far away your points are so if
your points are a certain distance away
then um when you get separated they're
going to incur a cost that's roughly for
K they're going to incur a cost that's
roughly the size of the
grid so if they're in two different
cells like here the cost is going to be
the size of one of these
cells and the probability that they're
separated is roughly the the the
distance between these two points now
for K means the probability they're
separated is still the distance between
the two points but the the cost now is
not this the the size of the cell it's
the size of the cell
squared and so you can work this
probability out and see that they're
arbitrarily bad
distortions
okay so um uh yeah uh the quatri
embedding doesn't work but the reason it
doesn't work is because uh when pairs of
points are too close to the boundary of
the hyper grid meaning that they should
be pretty close but then the hyper grid
separates them uh the hyper grid thinks
that the cost is really high but the
actual cost is really low so the bad
cases really happen when there's a
boundary that separates uh you know this
is exactly the Bad Case right
here so to fix this what we do is say
that we have a different construction on
the quad tree and we're going to do the
same thing as before but when a point is
too close to the boundary what we end up
doing is making a copy of this point uh
on the other
side okay so we project the center
across the the uh the boundary of the
hyper grid and now the point is that
these things are now in the same cell so
they don't have that much
Distortion now what's the condition that
we do this the condition is that um if
the points are within the the uh one
over D log Delta fraction of the side
length of the
grid and we need this choice so that we
can take a union bound over all log
Delta hyper grids with different
granularities and each of the D
dimensions and the other point is that
after we do this uh only order K new
centers will be created that's also
important if we have too many centers
that are created through this by
criteria method then the approximation
will will be
bad okay so we get a decent
approximation but the order of the
number of centers is like order
k um we can kind of replicate some of
our results for EMD sketch to show that
there exists a w scene sketch that has
uh some guarantee that's not great but
not good enough for our purposes and it
could also be done in um sublinear space
uh sub log space and handle insertion
deletion
uh
so now um the algorithm should be as the
same as before we set up the was sketch
in the first pass we run sparse recovery
in the second pass there's some
technical issues because the Distortion
is like uh log Delta which means we need
to sample log Delta points uh but we fix
that by storing like the offsets of the
points instead of the actual
points okay so I'll skip this but uh
yeah so the K means algorithm is that we
set up the watch SC sketch first pass
again run Spar recovery but what we
store is uh offsets of each of the
points from the sets of the centers
rather
than all right so um to summarize things
we give an algorithm for insertion only
we show that this problem is hard for a
single pass for insertion deletion and
then we give algorithms for uh multiple
passes
[Applause]
have time for a couple
questions so it's a bit of a generic
question but so the there's this like
mer and reduce technique it seems to
work for most problems and it almost
never give you optimal bounds and like
for quantile estimation there's this GK
summaries that is doing if you look at
it very far apart like it's
deterministic but it handles by saying
okay the merge are like you you get a
better guarantee through the tree you
are doing it by doing some sampling and
then passing it
to then passing it to this merge and R
is there something generic happening
that like is there a better merge and
reduce technique that you can design
that works let's say for all these
problems
is there a better merge and reduced
technique that we can do for all these
problems
[Music]
um maybe let's say a recipe that okay
this problem has a merge and rce what do
I need to do to make it like not lose
all these log
factors yeah I guess that's kind of uh
at the heart of what we're doing the
first pass like if we don't want it to
lose all these log factors in a stream
length uh uh well I guess the solution
is just have a smaller uh shorter stren
stream
um if you're still demanding that the
stream length is going to be close to
the original size um I don't see a way
of improving mergin
reduce but uh yeah I guess if uh you
don't need the stream length to be that
much then uh writing some
algorithm uh that would shorten
effective stream is basically our
message do you know for any of these
clustering problems that merge and
reduce give you the optimal bounds for
any problem that you can prove it is
optimal um so I guess Merchant reduce is
usually used for a stream right so are
you asking if uh it's optim a stream
yeah
um well I guess what we just showed is
that it's not optimal so and I guess
these are the problems that I've been
thinking the most about so I don't know
of any problems where Emergen
is all right thank
you
questions